hello my name is Jim Chapman and I've
just stopped by GQ where they fitted me
with an all new kind of suit
it's the stretchy suit you can read all
about it in the May issue or watch one
of their videos about how to style it
now the suit that you're seeing me in
right now is on theory I love the way it
looked and I can already feel that it is
lighter and more flexible than a
traditional suit
let's talk science this suit consists of
wall and a little bit of elastic which
is like elastic but less cheap and
weird-feeling one big advantage of a
stretch of soup is that they are nearly
impossible to wrinkle so they're great
for guys who travel you don't steam them
or iron them or take them to the dry
cleaner you put them straight out of
your case slip it on and you're ready to
go to a wedding or a meeting or just
walk around the street looking really
cool it is time to put this suit to the
test I'm going through running around
New York literally then probably on the
flight back home to London where I live
and of course are we documenting the
whole thing on my camera here
[Applause]
did you want this
I've been doing this for probably about
two hours now and this suit is really
stretchy I was doing this in my suits
from home they would all a grip around
the crotch region probably but this is
doing really well so far I'm going to
sleep I guess house hello so it's six
hours later now my flight was great I'm
back in Blighty back home in London and
the suit has fared very well at the
front I tear the back is quite wrinkled
belt but that being said it's done quite
well I could now go to a meeting but I'm
not going to my shower instead so thank
you very much for watching this video
have you learned something about stretch
of suit make sure you subscribe to Gigi
channel and of course myself Jim Kaplan
I'll see you very soon thank you